[Musique]
s'initier au tir à l'arc au basket en
fauteuil roulant et aussi à une dizaine
d'autres activités sportives
c'est le défi lancé par ces jeunes des
classes ulis qui concourent à la
première édition des ulis yade de l'est
précédente génération 2024 et on prépare
les jeux olympiques de paris et jeux
paralympiques justement nullis les
élèves peuvent prétendre avoir le statut
de paradis pour leur montrer un peu ce
qui existe ce qui peut être adapté à
leurs difficultés
c'est tout l'enjeu de ces initiales
faire découvrir à ses élèves en
situation de handicap les pratiques
sportives grâce à l'urss ils sont
environ 150 à parcourir les différents
ateliers
à tous
mal au bras
ça c'est si ça donne ceci complique
alors oui mais après ça c'est la vie et
c'est de faire découvrir déjà nos élèves
que bahia il ya d'autres handicaps ou si
il ya là on vient de sortir deux
c'est donc le foot pour les
personnes
malvoyante et voilà je pense que c'est
intéressant pour eux de découvrir
les ateliers de sensibilisation à la
nutrition et à la santé sont aussi
présents sur le parcours comme ici avec
le vélo ce mois ci
mais sur un vélo et on
mixer
que là on est
en attendant un atelier où on dire que
manger des fruits des légumes que
mental assez équilibré sable une
première édition riche de son succès qui
ambitionne de grandir encore un peu plus
l'année prochaine en s'ouvrant à tous
les collèges de l'île et pas uniquement
aux classes ulis
[Musique]